okay I'm waiting for a couple of our
members especially one of them has to
all right
I'm going to call the finance committee
to order for an exec session
on a group of bills mostly from division
one
so I will Begin by recognizing
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman before I get too
far into this I just want to thank the
members of division one we had something
like 26 bills initially we dispense with
some earlier we have I think 17 today
the work done by the division members
has been extremely good helpful and
we've come to a lot of good decisions I
think so
moving to the first bill House Bill 46
establishing a committee to study
replace the replacement of a bail
commissioner with a court magistrate
thank you do we have this amendment
um
Mr Hoffman's got one for you if you
didn't get it
too
it was moved by representative McGuire
and seconded by representative
cambrell's
well but what I see in front of me is 9
15 h
all right so I guess the paper I'm
looking at isn't right okay
um thank you very much Mr chairman so uh
this this bill uh the previous go around
removed the financial aspects so this is
now just a committee
um so it seems reasonable to to say off
the pass
[Music]
um
and
I personally think we don't want to
replace bail Commissioners but that's
just my personal opinion and why not let
the committee do what it wants to do is
is the amendment you're moving 9 15.
I guess so yeah on my paper it said 892h
but what I have in my hand is 9 15h
maybe we'll ask
um
I actually get an explanation the
amendment approved by the division it
was 915h
and it just made grammatical changes to
uh the bill
yeah there was like a wrong comma or
something like that okay
so did you move the amendment yes 915
nature
and representative Ambrose you want a
second
further discussion tell us what your
amendment was
attempting to do yeah this amendment
again is it's just a grammatical
correction that's all
the com the bill itself in the previous
committee amended out any Financial
aspects and so therefore this is just a
committee and for some of the confusion
I think we have more than one Amendment
before us
one applies to another bill
the one on the top it looks like is is
uh to 46 the one second pages to
Amendment 576 which we haven't come to
yet
so we've got two amendments stabled
together the one we're going to look at
is
zero nine one five you'll see how simple
that is
changes the one line
can we adopt by a show of hands
without objection all in favor
hands down any opposed
we have adopted the amendment
representative McGuire now moves I ought
to pass with Amendment
representative Campbell seconds
representative Mooney thank you Mr
chairman and thank you division one for
bringing this forward I certainly
respect the recommendation but I do just
want to explain I'll be voting no I have
a constituent who's a bail commissioner
she and I have had many of discussion
with regards to this conversion of bail
commissioner to magistrate I know also
there was a bill retained in criminal
justice this year House Bill 318 to
study this conversion as well and then
just in general the idea of a committee
on top of all the other work the
legislature has to do with regards to
this would be my reasons for voting no
or not to pass with Amendment House Bill
seeing none are you ready for the
question well excuse me representative
Hewitt for a question yes um
I'm a little bit confused here I've got
people two pieces of paper yeah the
first one uh on the the front one says
representative leishman Hillsborough 33
and it's an amendment to House Bill 46
FN that's what we're talking about
and the only thing about House Bill 46
is the same number that's over here I
understand that
is it immensely bill by replacing the
introductory paragraph with the
following which is three of the duties
of the committee is to evaluate whether
the bail commissioner should be replaced
um
and then on the on the next page
um we have an amendment to House Bill
576 FN
um apparently from representative
Sweeney
I don't know what's going on except that
in the beginning when God made the
little bills
um we had a bill that had been in that
had been introduced to abolish uh bail
Commissioners and replace them with uh
something else I think I think it was
magic uh
magistrates of some sort
uh the problem is that it didn't go over
very well with with the people out in
the field including representative
Mooney's of
Representative Mooney's uh
constituent and
also didn't go over very well with the
anybody representing the district court
system
um
the reason is that
the the provisions of the bill that was
was offered in the beginning
created a little bit of a problem in
that it just completely turned around
how the criminal justice system works in
terms of the arrest and prosecution of
defendants
the way the way it is now is if somebody
is arrested by the police
um a bail commissioner is called
and the veil commissioner determines
whether what kind of bail is is to be
imposed up until the time the person can
be brought to court
uh
what what is important about this is
that the kind of the kind of crimes
that bail Commissioners are called to
are
pretty generally misdemeanors
and
the
and the bail commissioner is supposed to
get a fee but the fee is to be paid by
the defendant
there are a few little issues with that
too
what this what the bill proposed or was
that the
the court in the first instance would be
the one that would set the uh the bail
but they would they would have
um
they would have magistrates to determine
what the bail should be in advance
that didn't make a lot of sense because
you would have to have a whole bunch of
magistrates in order to in order to
collect all the stuff that's being done
by bail Commissioners because there are
I don't know
40 50 bail Commissioners in the state
and each each district court has a bunch
of them in Superior Court it's a lot
different uh the in Superior Court
people that are accused with a crime are
arrested usually by the sheriff or by
where a police department and there
immediately brought two
the county jail
and there
Provisions are made for an amount of
bail to be set by a court
that would be very difficult in these
cases because
um
most of the crimes made rest made by the
police are
either motor vehicle motor vehicle
charges or simple assault and you know
larceny and stuff like that which don't
involve felonies
you know the such the situation that
would occur if you passed what
I thought the bill was about
uh is that the uh the person will be
would be
arrested and and brought somewhere we're
not sure where
and the court would eventually fix
amount of an amount of bail and the
people would be detained until that
happened and that could take some time
uh in terms of days rather than minutes
um the other the other part of this
that's uh kind of contested uh
particularly on the part of bail
Commissioners is that bail Commissioners
are entitled to fee
and the amount of the fee is set by a
law
but they have to collect the fee from
the defendant
right
and of course if the defendant is at the
county jail
and
the fee is I forget it was eighteen
dollars the last time I heard
um it isn't isn't it great
but the if the bail is set and the
defendant doesn't have any money
uh well they don't have the right to
hold them until the court can convene uh
so they've in in many cases the bail
commissioner doesn't get paid
house bill I have I have one I'm
supposed to write
a blurb on
um has has to do the same within the
same thing
um except that uh the uh
magistrates are people who are paid
by by Appropriations
and
I don't know how they're gonna how
they're going to get paid or how it's
going to be determined what happens to
the defendant and the bill the bill
wasn't very very clear about that
and that's why
um there's been this is uh
I don't know whether representative
liesman filed uh this amendment
2023-0915h
um but I know what where House Bill 646
is because I we most most of us
everybody on division one at least has a
copy of it in their binder so
I don't know what's going on I I don't
know
um
I wasn't aware that representative
leishman had filed an amendment house
bill 46.
and so I I'm confused and I I don't I'm
certainly not going to vote for the
motion as it stands because it turns the
criminal justice system uh on its ear
Mr chairman no I can't I have no I know
what a magistrate is in in the broad
sense it's a person who makes decisions
in um in legal matters that magistrates
aren't all sounds like a judge well yeah
it does sound like a judge except that I
don't think magistrates get paid like a
judge
so I I don't know I
I'll bring it back to representative
leishman thank you for your help
thank you Mr chairman the reason my name
is on the amendment it was a grammatical
change the LBA found so that was a
correction uh again just for clarity
this is a study committee it had no
Financial impact and that's why we voted
thank you further discussion on House
Bill 46 FN
representative hole thank you Mr chair
I'm hearing bipartisan resistance to an
autopath as an amended motion is there
an appetite to itl this or retain this
the vote before us is auto pass is
amended so that would have to be
defeated before we go for another motion
okay representative Sweeney thank you Mr
chairman so I just want to add that this
is a bill that went through its first
policy committee was amended to be the
study committee and then it kind of
wiped away the fiscal impact but due to
the process of the house it still came
to house finance in division one uh for
a second review even though it did not
have a fiscal impact it passed the first
policy committee I believe unanimously
it was on the consent calendar we
adopted on a Voice vote it's just a
little bit more of the history of the
bill here I'll be voting yes on ought to
pass as amended as there's no fiscal
impact there's really no purview for
finance here we're just moving this
along the process the house desires
thank you
resume Edwards uh thank you Mr chair I
intend to vote uh in favor of the
division recommendation I'm sure they
looked at this and they put together a
good amendments and I support their work
representative grassy uh yes Mr chairman
uh from what I understand this is a this
comes from to us from last year or last
session when we had the bill which was
affectionately known as a catch and
release most of our communities
particularly if you live in the cities
you get this a lot of responses from
your police departments so that people
have brought in bail Commissioners
are incapable of handling it and they're
released right back out on the streets
to commit another crime and so there was
a a lot of people who had problems with
that situation particularly when
Indigent people that we don't want to
lock them up but we also want to be able
to deal with the issue and that this was
a compromise that was brought forward to
instead of bail commission so let's have
magistrates maybe we can get this thing
through the process a little quicker you
have people who are more
um more knowledgeable of the situations
on on on when you can release somebody
without collecting a bail particularly
somebody who's Indigent or whether you
should hold those people
um what happened is is that the bill
wasn't
what everybody expected it to be
probably so they wanted to since I
wasn't here the first couple months when
this was held in the policy committee uh
that they wanted to take a look at and
study this I think it's looking for a
solution to a problem which does exist
people don't want to hold Indigent
people in in prisons and yet we need to
do something we just can't keep doing
the so-called Catch and Release because
our constituents are upset about things
like that so I don't look at this as
that there's much bipartisan opposition
I think we all agree that we need to
find a solution and this is what we want
to do is now study it to look for that
solution so I'll be voting yes on this
thank you
representative Hewitt now I'm in doing a
little more reading here
uh this is an amendment to house bill
576. it's that's just attached because
of convenience for passing them all out
so they wouldn't have to pass out two
bills at a time they'd staple them
together 576 were coming to later oh
okay
that's the last one on the uh on the on
the docket okay just a convenience for
passing them out so
we'd have and and also it got printed on
the other side as well so
that's really the whole economy of uh
economy of paper
but the the amendment
um
changes the bill whatever it was that
evaluates whether the bail commissioner
should be replaced or supplemented by a
court Magistrate
it's
well I'm not I'm not going to vote for
it because I really don't know where
it's going and I don't vote for Stuff
where I don't know where it's going
further
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
as amended the clerk will call the roll
thank you Mr chairman
representative McGuire
yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Griff representative
Griffin yes
representative Mooney no
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative hole
no
representative Sweeney yes
Arizona Campbells yes
yes
representative norgren
president Leachman yes
representative buco
yes
representative grassy yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
Arizona cholorski yes
representative hicken Phillips yes
I was going to string them yes
representative Wilder yes Mr chairman
motion passes
and we'll send this forward
send Maybe
not on consent
representative leishman is recognized on
House Bill 74.
thank you very much Mr chairman this is
relative to an employee's unused earned
time and I like to recognize
representing Kimbrell's to speak to the
motion of itl
thank you Mr chair this bill basically
what it would do is mandate employers to
pay the employees for unused vacation
time when they either retire get laid
off or leave the job
makes sense just common sense however
the the division one committee voted 5-3
to itl because what we found was this is
not a widespread issue it's it's common
good business policy for companies to
pay their employees for their vacation
time during testimony yes there were a
few very egregious cases that were
brought forth but they were few and far
between and there is also a process by
which the employees can go and challenge
not being paid anyway
so we just felt that we didn't need
additional legislation on employers
that's a contract between the employee
and the employer and they know what
they're doing when they when they get
together and they take a job and again
shame on any employer that doesn't pay
uh
their their employees for their vacation
time but again in this economy
they would do well to make sure that
they uh they treat the employees well
and that they would not uh have this bad
policy of not paying them for vacation
time so with that I would like to make a
motion to itl
is there a second
representative grassy
yes Mr chairman thank you
um I you know I I put a lot of what he
said representative said was was right
you know this something doesn't
necessarily happen a lot
um and it's also you know this bill only
deals with businesses that are over 15
employees so it doesn't affect some
really small employers and that it's bad
that employers don't pay their when
employers don't pay their employees and
it puts the onus
on the back of the employee to collect
any time that they need and sometimes
when you're laid off or let go abruptly
in your job for whatever reason it may
be many times no fault of your own
um you um you're you're then required to
go and figure out where how are you
supposed to complain about this and a
lot of times you're just too busy
looking for another job
I personally went through this
when covet hit
they came into our office this was in
March
came into our office and said you know
we want everybody to show up at 10
o'clock in the morning so I showed up at
10 o'clock that morning and they showed
because I had the night shift and
um they said oh by the way we're
shutting down at midnight
and I said you know do we have um
medical benefits they said you know your
medical benefits end at midnight and uh
and then they gave us they said we'll
have your checks for you you know
tomorrow uh here you know your checks
will be available to you
our vacation time I'd been there for 10
years our vacation time recruit on
January 1st those people who took their
vacations between January 1st and March
got their vacation time in their sick
time those of us who did not take our
vacation time me being one of them
because I usually take it in August lost
my vacation time they did not pay it
only happens a few times and you'd say
that you know in particularly in today's
employment people would want to make
sure they pay their employees well when
you when you're letting somebody go you
don't care if they like you or not when
you're shutting down you don't care if
they like you or not if it's only a few
cases this shouldn't be a problem it
should be zero cases
I'm going to ask to defeat the motion of
itl and so we can get this ought to pass
and get it out there because those
people who are let go you know they they
told me they said oh by the way you can
go on COBRA but when you're unemployed
Cobra doesn't make sense either my
vacation pay may have made a difference
at that point
and I would encourage you to vote no on
this motion and so that we can get ought
to pass and get this to the floor so
that we can treat all employees
favorably
representative propovici Miller
thank you Mr chair I just want to point
out that while the intent of the bill is
to right or wrong every bill that we
pass has the potential for unintended
consequences and one of the very
predictable unintended consequences is a
very popular practice in the biotech
sector where I now have two family
members employed in up from one
and that's called unlimited vacation
time and what they mean by unlimited
vacation time is that you get as much
vacation as you can get approved by your
supervisor
but you also don't have any accrual of
vacation time because it's not a limited
amount of vacation time and therefore
there is nothing to accrue for because
you have unlimited vacation
guess what happens when you get let go
there is no vacation time to be paid off
I would rather not give employees
incentives to stop offering regular
vacation time that's accrued and it gets
paid to most people when they leave
and frankly when an employee goes
bankrupt they can have any obligations
they want there is no blood you can get
out of a stone when they are insoluble
they are insoluble I will vote to itl
this because of concerns over the
unintended consequences thank you
representative Griffin
I I recognize all the comments that have
been made
but if you read the bill you'll find
that there's
a lot of bookkeeping requirements placed
on companies
and I think with the with the few
instances
unfortunately representative Gracie's
was a victim of it but there aren't that
many
uh
incidences Statewide we found very few
and I think the owner's provisions of
all the bookkeeping Provisions for this
outweigh
those those isolated
instances
representative
um just to comment on the financial
aspects of this there is a fiscal note
on here that says 4.5 million but that
would affect the budget if every single
state employee quit at the same time and
so we understood from the uh from the
prime sponsor that during testimony and
the hearing commissioner Arling house
actually said that the financial hit of
this would be absolutely de minimis and
we did hear that there are very few
related claims
so if you're looking at it from a
budgetary standpoint there was a de
any further questions or discussions
seeing none the clerk will call the role
the motion is itl on House Bill 74.
thank you Mr chairman
representative McGuire
yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbells
yes
representative Mueller yes
representative norbury no
representative grassy no
representative Hewitt no
representative Heath no
president Murray no
there's an evil no
Rosanna tolorski no
representative hicken Phillips
no
Arizona Wilder
yes
Mr chairman a vote is 13 to 11 in favor
of the motion
the motion is itl and this one can go on
no it still won't go on consent
may I have a may I ask a question Mr
chair
go ahead uh did is there a blurb author
for 46 FN and now for 74 FN both for and
against
I'll write the one 446 since I made the
motion
representative Campbell's for 74.
yes I had written one for the division
would that suffice to present the same
one yes thank you and are there are
there any minority reports
there will be
okay represent grassy on House Bill 74.
is there one on 46 uh
I don't believe there will be one on 46.
okay moving on to House Bill 212 212
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman so this is a
appropriating funding and for vet
investigations and testing and
monitoring relative to pfafs this came
to us with an
appropriation request of two million
dollars and changing the pfaff's Loan
Fund to pfas response fund
the division is looking to retain it and
okay and retain does not require a
report
further discussion on the motion to
retain
so it's it's representative leishman
do we have a second second
representative
Mr chair
representative McGuire so we do expect
to put something of this in the house
bill too but I don't believe it's
necessarily the entire funding that the
bill itself has
yeah that's usually understood on when
we retain a bill we'll put in what we
can
when we come to that portion of the
budget
further discussion on the motion to
retain representative Abel yeah
I just wanted to clarify there actually
will be no
appropriated with this what's happening
is that we decided to
make the language changes that were in
the bill
but to allow Des to use a certain
portion of the money which it otherwise
wouldn't have been able to by
um by expanding the language and the and
it says that they can use 10 of the
appropriation for investigation and the
other things provided in the bill so
thank you
further discussion on retain for house
bill 212.
seeing none you're ready for the
question the clerk will call a roll on
clerk will call a role to retain on
House Bill 212.
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes president
Bean
represent a hole
yes
Arizona Sweeney yes
Arizona Campbells yes
yes
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes representative
grassy
yes
representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
evil yes
representative yes
representative haken Phillips
yes
I was gonna Stringham yes representative
Wilder
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 in favor to
retain thank you and the only thing that
needs to go on the calendar is the list
of bills we retain
moving on to House Bill 230
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman this is directing
the Department of Agriculture markets
and foods to employ an electronic data
processing system
the division supports this and is
retaining it and putting this in House
Bill too and
the numbers specifically in the Bill of
course could change because we have not
made a final decision but we're asking
moves to retain is there a second
representative or okay which one I guess
is representative Abel's turn
now wish to retain okay the clerk will
call a roll on the motion to retain
thank you Mr chairman
representative yes
I'm sorry representative McGuire yes
Arizona petroval GS
representative yes
Rosanna Griffin yes represent a Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative hole yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner
representative Auburn yes
Arizona Leachman yes Regina Buco yes
representative grassy yes
version of Hewitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes Arizona
Swarovski yes
president haken Phillips yes it was in a
Stringham yes and representative water
yes
Mr chairman of vote is 25-0 in favor to
retain
thank you
move on to House Bill 234 representative
Legion
thank you Mr chairman this is relative
to renewable energy credits one of the
few bills that you'll see from us
without recommendation I'd call a
okay well I move
ought to pass on HB 234
second
thank you very Motion in a second to
ought to pass on House Bill 234 for the
yes at the financial effect and there is
absolutely no discernible Financial
effect to the
budget it really is more of um
I would say a policy issue regarding the
use of renewable energy credits and
whether they can be swept by utility
companies instead of
um
I have to say this right I'm not an Ste
person uh that wreck sweeping has
decimated the New Hampshire Rec market
and significantly decreased alternative
compliance payments the only source of
funding for the renewable fund which is
our state's Soul mechanism for investing
in the clean energy transition ending
Rec sweeping might arguably increase
electricity bills buy Pennies on the
average monthly bill but renewable
energy Investments pay off in lower
demand for fossil fuel lower Peak demand
improved air quality more jobs and
increased in-state economic activity so
I would urge the committee to pass this
bill in favor of the House vote and in
light of the fact that it has no effect
further discussion representative
McGuire
thank you Mr chairman yes I I agree that
this is not really a finance bill and so
uh probably we should just simply vote
on it as we did in the house floor but
I'm opposed to this particular policy
um because it it basically would
redirect roughly three million dollars a
year from rate payers into this
particular fund
um and that that's the main uh purpose
of the bill but but our electric rates
are extremely high at the moment and
um rate payers need all the help they
further discussion representative
Campbell's thank you Mr chair yes I also
agree with representative evil that this
is probably uh this is a policy issue
having been on Science and Technology
I'm very familiar with the issue and I
can tell you that from a financial
standpoint it does affect the rate
payers in a negative way so
um I would vote to not not pass this
bill I would vote to itl it
representative papavichi Milner
One Financial aspect of this is that it
will make electricity more expensive for
everybody including the government so it
does have an impact on us even though
it's not a huge impact
and we do have an obligation to try to
run the government that uh you know as
low cost as possible so I'm planning to
further discussion from committee
members representative Abel thank you
well I know for people who've worked
very hard on this I would be remiss if I
didn't say that by investing in
renewable energy you do ultimately lower
electricity costs for all so that is a
reason to pass it
further discussion representative Hull
thank you Mr chair having installed and
designed and installed solar systems for
myself and others
the issue is not the amount of solar
power we have a peak energy usage
between 4 pm and about 8 PM every day
and even if we build more solar we still
have to supplement all of that with
additional
um more trustworthy sources of energy
whether that's natural gas oil coal
hydroelectric
Nuclear So as much as I like the idea
it doesn't solve the real issue until we
start addressing Peak shaving
further discussion from the committee
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on the motion of ought to pass
president McGuire no representative
Petrie votes you know
representative Emrick go
representative Griffin no
representative Mooney no
representative Edwards no
no representative Bean
representative hole no
representative Sweeney no
Representative cambrose no
representative malware no
representative Wallner
representative yes
representative leishman yes
representative buco
yes representative grassy yes
representative Hewitt yes representative
Heath yes representative Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative yes
representative haken Phillips yes
representative Wilder
no
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in a
negative
the motion fails
Mr chairman I move in expedient to
legislate
representative McGuire moves an
expedient to legislate it was executed
clerk will call the roll on the motion
of
legislate on House Bill 234
thank you Mr chairman
representative yes yes
president McGuire yes Rosanna Petrie
Voss yes representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
representative hole yes
representative Sweeney yes
representative Kimbrell's yes
representative Mahler yes
representative walner
representative norgren
no
Representative leishman no
representative bucco no representative
grassy no
Arizona Hewitt no
representative Heath no representative
Murray nope
representative evil
Representative jalorski no
no president Higgin Phillips no
no representative Stringham no
representative Weiler
yes
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12 in the
no it will not go on consent
representative leishman is recognized
for house bill 250.
thank you Mr chairman this is relative
to accidental death benefits payable to
group two members however we discovered
there may be a possible problem with an
amendment we voted on this morning so
we'd like to pull this off for your
consideration
Mr chairman why not
um
don't we have a deadline
so we ought to at least retain if if
I'm trying to remember if this is the
30th it might be
uh do we have anything on this that
House Bill 234 will there be both a
majority and a Minority Report
majority minority Minority Report
representative evil
thank you
you got it already Okay that makes it
easy
right we we can delay it we do have this
March 30th as the as the uh
there's a deadline on that one
all right house bill 270 represented
that's division two representative
representative thank you Mr chair uh 250
is
272. I mean
I mean and so I moved to retain
motion to retain is there a second
further discussion from committee
members
representative Mooney
thank you Mr chairman I'll be sporting a
motion to retain with the understanding
that this will be added to House Bill 2.
I'm the prime sponsor of House Bill 272
as well as a supporter I'll be voting in
favor to retain just a little background
this bill came out of the house
education committee 19-1 came out of the
Full House
348 to 11. and came out of division two
with a unanimous recommendation to
retain and place in house bill 2.
right now charter school students per
pupil receive at their schools
approximately seventy three hundred
dollars per pupil
that amount was set in 2017.
this bill along with the governor's
proposal inadequacy Aid would then bring
the number up to nine thousand dollars
per pupil for Charter School students
certainly an increase that is deserved
and certainly one well worth the wait
since it hasn't happened since
2017. so with that again I'll be voting
to retain with the understanding that it
will go in House Bill 2. thank you
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call the roll
on retain for House Bill 272. thank you
Mr chairman representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative cameras yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Wallner
representative norgren yes there's
another leashman yes
representative Buco yes representative
grassy yes representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes representative evil yes
representative orsky yes president
hicken Phillips yes I'm sorry
yes
Weiler I get it I'll get it yes thank
you
Mr chairman of vote is 25 just over to
retain
representative Leachman is recognized
for house bill 276.
thank you Mr chairman this is to
establish a sign
cyanobacteria mitigation loan Grant fund
we're going to really retain this not
put it in House Bill too I don't know
whether representative McGuire would
like to speak to this or not
thank you very much Mr chairman so
um this bill has a very uh laudable goal
to reduce
cyanobacteria in lakes and
um ponds but it
um the the funding mechanism in the bill
was extremely problematic it proposed
that we borrow 25 million dollars and
then use it to make loans and grants in
a in a fairly
undirected way you know it had um
uh
very uh broad rule-making Authority Etc
so we we need to
um we need to retain this to really get
the funding mechanism uh right thank you
was there a second order
representative's
further discussion from committee
members on the on House Bill 276.
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
thank you Mr chairman representative URF
yes representative McGuire yes
representative OCS representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Campbells yes
representative Mueller yes Reverend
Walter
representative norgren
yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes representative
grassy yes representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes original evil
yes
representative yes
representative Phillips yes
Stringham yes
representative Weider yes
thank you
moving on to House Bill 300
representative leishman thank you Mr
chairman so this is to
prohibiting the disposal of certain food
waste actually establishes a new
position called a waste management
specialist three and I know
representative evil would love to speak
comes to
20-0 recommendation of ought to pass
from environment of Agriculture it
passed in the house on a voice Voice
vote
it also comes to us with a unanimous
recommendation to retain for HB 2 from
our division it's really
um
uh the culmination of a lot of work
starting with the creation of a new
Solid Waste Management plan
it was recommended and and part of the
solid waste management plan is that we
really have to start to put Less in our
landfills to preserve the landfill space
for ourself and for things that other
you can't do other with 25 of all that
goes into
landfills in terms of weight is food
waste so this um
would prohibit the disposal of food
scraps by generators of one ton or more
of food scraps a week and the diversion
requirement would only apply if there
was a place for these food scraps to go
within 20 miles and it also
asks that the way you divert the food
scraps is first by feeding humans second
by animals and thirdly by composting or
anaerobic digestion this Bill had
absolutely no opposition in the division
or in committee it was supported by
Waste Management which is a landfill
operator it was also supported by
um
by the food banks folks because they're
really excited at the prospect of more
food to be donated and I would
appreciate a vote to retain it for the
budget
further discussion from committee
members on the motion to retain
and who second the retain representative
Sweeney
clerk will call the role on the motion
to retain on House Bill 300.
thank you Mr chairman representative
Earth yes representative McGuire yes
representative
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yes representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes president
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative cambrose yes
representative Mueller yes
representative walner
Russia norgren yes representative
leishman yes representative Buco yes
represent grassy
representative Hewitt yes president
Heath yes representative Murray yes yes
version of evil yes
yes representative haken Phillips yes
yes representative Stringham yes
Russian Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0 to retain
house bill 300.
I will make the motion of ought to pass
and
speak to the
in a second from representative McGuire
I was involved with the reserves for
many years and and also the National
Guard a bit and
there it's a very competitive thing
especially in a small state like ours
they could shop around to see what will
they get from Massachusetts or Maine or
some other state we need to keep the
troops up in case of emergencies in the
state obviously some of them have now
been called to be prison guards because
of the shortage there and the National
Guard people usually called up an
emergencies for covering up for for
plowing and whatever else needs to be
done in floods and so on so it's
important so this bill takes money it's
not General funds it comes from fines
that are
in a military court and puts him in a
fund presently the in
the enlistment incentive is 500 this
doubles it to a thousand and they think
it's it's going to cost about fifty
thousand a year but it's covered by the
fines and fees so it's not a problem for
us with the general fund so I think it's
needed I think it's necessary and I
think we got a good vote on it I move on
to pass and McGuire seconds it thank you
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
or not to pass on House Bill 330.
thank you Mr chairman representative URF
yes president McGuire yes representative
don't love me anymore I I don't like you
no more representative Emrick yes
representative Mooney
yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
it was in a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative kimbrells yes
representative Mueller yes Arizona
walner
there was an organ yes it was in a leaf
leashman yes representative bucco yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hewitt yes representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes representative
Ebel yes
yes representative yes representative
haken Phillips yes
there's gonna Stringham yes
represent a Waller yes
Mr chairman of motion passes 25 to zero
autopass
thank you turning the page over
we'll see House Bill 337 FN and
representative leishman is recognized
thank you Mr chairman
um this will assure hopefully that the
office of professional licensure and
certification will provide notice of
public meetings and allow for public
comment the vote was nine to zero vought
to pass representative McGuire moves yes
I move out to pass
is there a second second by
representative Griffin
um may I speak Mr chairman speak yes so
the fiscal note for this says up to a
hundred thousand dollars a year but we
think this will be next to zero
um and it also shows that it could be
General funds but the but the office of
professional licensure is
um moving off budget sort of they're
they're going to be funded strictly from
their fees uh through a dedicated fund
and so this will not be General funds
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call the role
ought to pass on House Bill 337.
thank you Mr chairman representative yes
representative McGuire yes
representative Petrie votes yes
representative amrick yes representative
Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative Kimbrell's
yes
representative popovichi Mueller yes
representative Wallner
representative norgren yeah
yeah representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes representative
grassy yes representative Hewitt yes
representative Heath yes
representative Murray yes
representative Ebel
yes
representative yes haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25-0
thank you representative leishman is
recognized for house bill 347.
thank you Mr chairman this is
establishing a superior court land use
review docket representative McGuire
will move I'm over retain and we're
further discussion on House Bill 347.
um Mr chairman representative McGuire
thank you so
um this is an extra judge and the judge
is going to be tasked with with uh land
use cases all land use cases will go to
this particular new Superior Court Judge
the judiciary's own budget already had
the extra judge this is the 22nd uh
Superior Court judge
um but this bill
has all the language in it that that
makes them the judge work on land use
cases and so that will be going into
further discussion from committee
members seeing none the clerk will call
the roll on retain for house bill 347.
thank you Mr chairman
representative erf yes president McGuire
yes representative representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative
representative hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative yes
representative papovichi molar yes
representative walner
there's an organ yes representative
leishman yes representative Buco yes
representative grassy yes representative
Hewitt yes representative Heath yes
version of Murray yes version of evil
yes
representative tolorski yes there's an
hake and Phillips yes
representative Stringham
yes
representative water
Mr chairman the voters 25-0 to retain
thank you Mr chairman this is requiring
notice for anyone being evicted and what
their legal recourse could be through
Council
and I would recognize representative
Weiler
this bill is simple and requires an
attorney
but or
for actions against tenants
right to counsel for Indigent attendance
am I reading the wrong Bill no you're
all except excuse me Mr chairman um this
is just a simple notification
requirement so if somebody receives an
eviction notice they are given their
rights so to speak if they want to seek
counsel to help them with their eviction
Mr chairman if you'd like me to help you
I think you probably have the blurb
written already so I could get use the
old one I think I'd be fine all right so
represent thank you representative
McGuire moves
ought to pass on House Bill 379
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call a roll
the motion is ought to pass on House
Bill 379.
thank you Mr chairman
representative yes representative
McGuire yes Arizona Petrie voters
representative Emrick yes representative
Griffin yeah representative Mooney yes
representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
it was in a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes
yes representative mower yes
representative Waller
there's a representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative Buco yes Rosen aggressi
yes representative Hewitt yes
representative Murray
you forgot Representatives that's okay I
okay very good
uh representative Heath yes
version of evil yes
representative tolorski yes
representative haykin Phillips yes
yes representative Stringham yes
representative Weiler
yes did anybody not get called
I made sure that Mr chairman and my
count comes out at 24 instead of 25. no
it's 25.
I guarantee it all right I missed one
very good this motion is not to pass
um thank you for representative McGuire
for writing the report
and I guess this has money in it or does
it not no money like this can go on
consent
is this consent yeah okay very good no
minority for it
what was the question three three seven
I think that had a little money in it
well supposedly if it has money in it we
shouldn't put it on consent so we'll be
on a regular calendar okay
we'll move on to House Bill 462
representative representative leishman
is recognized
thank you Mr chairman this is making an
appropriation to the solid waste
management fund
and targeting food waste reduction and
diversion
I will ask representative Ebel to move
this and I know she wishes to speak to
this as well
we're
paying this bill has been put it into
hb2 this is another bill that comes from
the
Ena committee with a 20-zip vote in
favor of passing and voted on it um it
passed on a Voice vote it was uh the
motion to retain was seven to zero
within the division this had absolutely
no opposition it was supported by quite
a few folks in particular the New
Hampshire Municipal Association among
others this
um
this bill
expands the uh
sources from which the fund can be
financed to include more than EPA grants
which it had been limited to before I
think through oversight and it also adds
language to Target the use of the fund
for food waste diversion until
2027 50 percent of it could be targeted
for food waste diversion I already
explained why why food waste diversion
is really important in the context of
our landfills this also will help us
begin to make more projects I mean
progress in keeping things out of our
landfills and you know I would just say
there's increasing concern about pfas
and not that this is a direct line to
pfas reduction but let's face it the
less waste we put in our landfills where
so much waste has pfas pfas goes in the
landfill leachate which goes to our
wastewater treatment plants so I think
this is a win-win across the board and
it has a substantial true bipartisan
support as far as co-sponsorship so I'd
appreciate your support thank you
thank you
seeing none
the clerk will call the roll on retained
on House Bill 462.
thank you Mr chairman I had to take a
break very good representative erf yes
representative McGuire yes Arizona
Petrie votes yes representative Emrick
yes representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney
yes representative Edwards yes
representative Bean
version of hole yes representative
Sweeney yes representative cambrose yes
yes representative Wallner
representative norgren yes
representative leishman yes
representative yes representative grass
seed yes representative Hewitt yes
Arizona Heath yes representative Murray
yes
foreign
representative tolorski yes
there's an haken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yep
representative Weiler yes
Mr chairman the vote is 25 Discerning
thank you
moving on to House Bill four 504 504
representative policeman
thank you very much Mr chairman this is
relative to The Adult Parole Board in
and it's moved by representative Hewitt
I'd ask representative Hewitt to speak
to his motion once he has a second
thank you Mr chairman
um
just Advantage because I didn't bring my
notes with me this afternoon uh the
adult parole parole board deals with
everybody who gets some imprisoned at
the New Hampshire state prison and when
it comes down time for that parole
either based on the amount of time
they've spent or some other uh reason
like a court order
um
they have to appear before the Adult
Parole Board
and as my memory serves me the parole
board sits with five members
and uh
what they do is they hear whatever
information that the uh
prison system and the uh
and the and the people who deal with the
prisoners after they've released until
their whole their whole sentence has
been expired
um
the the Mona it's mostly a money Bill to
increase the uh staff of the board
because there's only they only have they
only have two two
actives inside the uh built inside the
the board this they do the paperwork
that it set gets separated amongst all
the uh all the participants and then uh
every month they have a total of two at
two sessions of the parole board
it's it's a little bit odd because you
don't think of the parole board as being
much of anything as far as
as far as spending money is concerned
but it's surprising when you find out
the the number of people who are
sentenced to the state prison is rather
substantial
and they have
um
they were there were over 100 people
that uh that come before the parole
board during the course of a a season
and um
they make twice a month
and the whole the whole uh thrust of the
bill is to
uh
to spend money in terms for example it
spends uh ten thousand dollars
um
per
year that's an annual stipend and they
want to increase it uh
from 20 actually they pay twenty
thousand they want to increase it by ten
thousand to thirty thousand uh and it
also allows former parole board members
to sit in hearings I want a full panel
of three cannot be attained
that's interesting because not many
people want to serve on the parole board
uh and with all of the uh all of the
cases they have that which involve a lot
of information that has to be gathered
by the small staff
um
not many people want to serve what if
they're not a member and and mostly the
only people who can serve other than the
actual
um actual board members our former board
members
and uh they most of them don't have a
really glowing history or glowing
sense of what went on in the proceedings
and also it's a pretty uh it's a pretty
nasty stuff
so
um
the amount of money that was being asked
for is uh thirty thousand dollars to
increase the size of the board
and increase the the
uh
the
the increase of increasing steps they've
been for the vice chair of 20 to 20
thousand dollars
and uh
former members are paid 300 a pop for
for the times that they sit the portal
board sits twice a month
and the uh and the
hearings
involved quite quite a bit of time and
they're kind of contentious at times I
imagine
so this is this is a simple build to
just
beef up the adult parole board so that
they don't have a lot of delays because
if you if you don't have people to serve
on the board uh or you don't have enough
people to serve on the board parole
hearings get delayed and that isn't a
very good feeling for particularly for
the participants and it makes the parole
board members concerned about the
adequacy of the job that they're doing
so uh the committee voted uh seven to
two
uh to a subgritty voted seven to two to
thank you representative Hewitt moves
representative walner seconds
further comments from the committee
so the bill really actually does two
things
and I think judge Hewitt um
representative Hewitt
outlined them but the first the first
part of the bill allows the chair of the
parole board
to
use
pre people who had previously served on
the parole board to sit in when he could
not find three members three of the
regular members to sit on a hearing this
has been a problem and he need it really
backs them up when they have to delay
the hearings because they can't get
three members so this just allows him to
use previous members to be basically
substitutes and he asked for for five
days a year that he could use someone as
a substitute and that it would be they
would be paid at three hundred dollars a
day
the second part of the bill actually
talks about the stipend of the members
the um chair of the parole board is
actually a state employee
and there's no no increase in the
stipend for for the um chair there are
um three members
who are regular members they're now paid
ten dollar uh ten thousand dollars a
year uh this would raise them another
ten to twenty thousand and the
um Vice chair
is now
um paid twenty thousand I'm sorry the
vice chair
um gets would raise to thirty thousand
now I know that sounds like
big raises but these are well qualified
people and difficult to find
often they're
um lawyers
they're often people who have actually
worked in the prison system and have
retired
they're very difficult to find and this
work is not easy
it takes many many many hours to prepare
for a parole hearing they also do
revocations so if someone was losing
their parole they'll also do those so
this is really difficult work and our
stipends have been low and this will
hopefully increase the pool of people
who would be willing to serve on the
parole board and I think as Citizens if
we stop and think about this this is a
really important duty they have for
safety in our communities putting people
out on parole a serious business so
um I hope that you'll support the bill
representative McGuire and thank you Mr
chairman I I do support the bill
um I just want to correct the the
numbers
um
no problem it's just the parole board
has five members the chair is a
full-time state employee the other four
are currently paid twenty thousand
dollars each this bill would raise the
vice chair to forty thousand and the
other three members to thirty thousand
but there but the
representative walner is exactly correct
that these are very experienced people
retired judges attorneys I think in one
case we have like a former Commissioner
of of Corrections from another state you
know this kind of thing so so
um this is really not uh they're working
I think close to full-time or quite
significant amount of time and not
representative Campbell's thank you Mr
chair for the record I was one of the
ones in division that voted against this
um and thank you representative Walnut
for making it clear to the committee
exactly what the bill did have no issue
with the first part for the temporary
people getting the money however I
didn't see the justification I don't
agree with representative McGuire
looking at the hours that these people
put in I did not see a justification for
giving a 50 raise and a 100 raise for
the chair given their track record it's
not only that they haven't put in as
much time as you would think they would
be but the track record of the parole
board is not exactly Stellar uh and I
don't know anybody else in the state or
in any occupation that gets 50 or 100
raises so on principle I voted against
it again I'm not against the I know the
parole board does uh you know it's a
very important job and it's and it's a
job that has a lot of stress I'm sure
but uh but I I just couldn't justify
though that kind of a percentage raise
for these positions and they are as you
said retired lawyers and judges you know
boohoo I'm not making a lot of money I'm
sure they're already rich so
representative Edwards
so thank you Mr chair I I estimate I
make about three cents an hour and
I I'm just curious uh has anyone done
the math to sort of figure out how many
hours what the hourly rate turns out to
be for say the vice chair who will be
raised to forty thousand
so thank you Massey yeah all right Susan
McGuire not specifically but first of
all if I remember correctly they do meet
weekly and on Tuesday they do
um parole hearings for seven roughly 17
um inmates and then on Thursdays they do
revocation hearings which are for uh
people who violate their parole whether
they should be remanded back into prison
so typically that would be about half
that number so say eight so so they get
very thick packets of paper that they
have to prepare for those you know so
the the here the Tuesdays and Thursdays
are sort of all day but there's there's
you know I don't know 40 pages or
something worth a paper on each each
individual so there's a lot of prep work
as well so it's a lot of work
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair so so I I think I'm going to vote
against this so that if it passes
they're going to be very grateful to all
of you and I'm going to hope that they
representative hole and then I think
representative Hewitt still has a light
on I'll come to you second
representative hole thank you Mr chair
um additional clarification from
representative Maguire on how often they
meet is helpful but I I have to admit I
have
um some concerns
in line 16 through 20 relative to the
base pay going from twenty to thirty
thousand dollars and the vice chairman
from 20 to 40. if I recall our executive
Council lawyers who meet twice a month
and have something on the order of ten
thousand pages to read between those
hearings on contracts get seventeen
thousand dollars or so
um
and granted those are elected positions
not not employee positions
um is there any way to divide this
because I'm really in favor of section
foreign
normally we deal with the whole bill in
its entirety the speaker may decide to
divide it when it comes to the floor
but normally in a committee we don't
make such decisions
thank you
representative heward relative to the
amount of money being paid these these
are not laborers these are all these are
all people mostly they're mostly
professional people
and
um
they
they work a lot of they work a lot of
hours but we have to bear in mind that
we are dealing with people who are
performing a very difficult task
uh and on the issue of uh them not doing
a very good job because not everybody is
is successful you're talking with people
who have spent time in the state prison
and they didn't spend time in the state
prison for not going through for going
um
recidivism is is a subject that is dealt
with all the time and it's argued about
um but these these people who serve on
the board are professionals and uh they
understand what the the success rate is
not
um 100 percent
and
you're gonna you they have they have a
hard time hiring uh
parole board members when there's a
vacancy uh so
I don't see any reason why you know the
the this the increase at this time which
hasn't happened in quite a few years uh
shouldn't be made
they earn every penny of every of every
representative cam cameras and then
represent a pump of each evening thank
you Mr chair I'll just reiterate I keep
hearing they work a lot of hours they
work a lot of hours but I'm an engineer
and when when I heard the testimony they
meet on Tuesday they meet on Thursday I
wasn't I didn't see a full-time job
there anywhere and I didn't see a lot of
uh that it was a part-time thing as far
as I was concerned so if if you're going
to keep throwing out that they work a
lot of hours I'd like somebody to
representative Mueller thank you Mr
chair no I'm not an expert in the legal
system
but I used to be a network administrator
and this has something to do in common
with uh you know being on the parole
board which is that nobody ever tells
you thank you when you get it right but
boy when you may get it wrong you will
hear from people and
I'm not saying they are perfect I'm not
saying they don't have but you know but
it's a darn hard job and you only hear
about it when you do it when something
goes wrong so it's just a tough job and
I I'm not really that qualified to
comment on whether the you know
compensation is appropriate or not I'll
probably follow the committee
recommendation but
I just want to say that it's it's one of
those where it's really hard to do it
and frankly the fact that we are having
a hard time getting people to serve is a
hint that you know
they are not that overpaid or you'd have
further discussion from committee
members
seeing none the clerk will call the role
on ought to pass on House Bill 504
representative Earth yes
representative McGuire yes
yes
representative Emrick yes
representative Mooney yes
representative hole no
Representative kimbrose no
representative Pope avici Mueller yes
representative walner
there's a norgren yes
president Leachman yes
representative bucco yes representative
grassy yes
president Hewitt
representative Heath yes representative
Murray yes
representative evil yes
representative yes
representative hicken Phillips yes
representative Stringham yes
representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 20 to 5 in favor
Maybe
if you have one have it done within the
hour okay
so that's a maybe is that that sounds
the emotion uh
HP 504 is adopted
ought to pass 20 to five moving on to
okay thank you Mr chairman this is to
establish a chief information security
officer for the Department of
Information Technology and I'd like to
recognize representative McGuire and
motion of ought to pass on 519 seconded
by representative evil
so this is a very simple bill that just
changes some titles in uh in the law for
for the some high-ranking employees in
the information technology department
um the these employees are already hired
they're already in this position it's
just a matter of giving them an official
title uh in the law so this could easily
further discussion from the committee
seeing none the motion is ought to pass
on House Bill 519
Rosen of Earth yes
representative McGuire yes president
Petrie votes yes representative Emrick
yes
representative Griffin yeah Mooney yes
it was in Edwards yes to support the
sponsor representative Bean
Arizona hole
yes representative Sweeney yes
president Campbell's yes there's another
yes
representative Waller
Rosa norgren yes Rosanna leishman yes
Arizona buco
yes
original grassy yes representative
Hewitt
version of Heath yes president Murray
yes there's no evil yes
representative yes representative
Phillips yes
president Stringham
yes
there's no water yes
Mr chairman of vote is 25-0 and auto
is there any money in this bill
that can go on consent
moving on to House Bill 534 recognize
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman the next one deals
with water assistance for natural
disasters and like to recognize
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman I move in expedient to
legislate
is there a second representative Griffin
so
this bill has a sort of laudable purpose
but it has two major flaws in in my mind
so what it does is it um allocates five
million dollars and puts it into a
special fund that would be used for
um to assist
low-income homeowners if they're
drinking water supply was interrupted by
a natural disaster
so apparently this has happened in the
past via the drought which hopefully is
over at this point
um and and Des used money
more General drinking fund money
drinking water money to to implement
something like this particular program
but this creates something new creates a
new fund and so on
so
um the two problems are one is it's
creating a bucket of money that's very
special purpose right it has to be for
low income for drinking water created
with where the problem was created by a
natural disaster
but if you think about it
you generally don't want disaster money
to be to be bucketed in that way you
would rather have a very large pool of
money to deal with natural disasters
because you don't know ahead of time
what kind of a disaster it's going to be
and what it's going to affect so for
example if you had a large fire or
something you couldn't use the money in
this fund for that because this fund
would be very targeted and so rather
than having this money in the special
fund that's sort of what the rainy day
fund is for right we we would we would
if we don't spend the money this way and
we don't spend it in any other way it
would end up in the rainy day fund the
rainy day fund is a general purpose fund
for disasters and other special
circumstances right so so it doesn't
really make sense to have you know try
to think of all possible kinds of
disastrous circumstances and have a
special pot of money for each one that's
the main problem there's also a problem
in is in that in my mind this bill
violates
um house rule 45d which says that we
should not be
issuing broad rulemaking authority to
departments uh we shouldn't have bills
with broad rulemaking Authority this
bill does not specify the meaning of low
income so what what income level would
count the amount of Any Given award you
know what what limits there might be on
the award this doesn't specify exactly
what's meant by a disaster
how the money would be used
Etc so this just basically it it also
gives Des the ability to use the money
in the fund for their expenses but it
doesn't say you know limited to five
percent or something like that right so
there's no limits on the amount of money
that could be used for their expenses so
so in general this is what this is a
classic broad rulemaking Authority uh
Bill and and again that's that's against
house rules in in my reading so for all
those reasons I think this should be in
expedient to legislate thank you Mr
chairman
seeing none
representative hack and Phillips thank
you Mr chair I just want to mention that
you'll see at the top of the co-sponsor
list that I am one of the co-sponsors
for this bill
and you know something that hasn't been
discussed yet at this point although it
was discussed in the original policy
committee which passed
um or I'm sorry I think it was tied and
it came to the floor and passed
um is that you know we have a housing
affordability and housing crisis on our
hands
um here in the state of New Hampshire
and given the real
um
real effects of the continuing drought
in our state especially in the Southern
Tier
we know that there are several
low-income families who are really
struggling with this issue
and that you know any step that we can
take any tool we can put in our toolbox
to assist those folks to stay in their
homes where they are to be able to have
drinking water
um reinstated or you know repaired is a
huge step in the right direction for our
communities and our state
um so I have a hard time
um although I do understand the
important arguments representative
McGuire outlined today
um that five million dollars to assist
these really needy folks is an important
step in the right direction
um for that reason I believe that
um I'm gonna have to say no to the vote
of itl and
um support the my the Primary Response
are as well as my co-sponsors for the
initial idea and hope that you know if
retention is a better
outcome from this committee I think that
it's worthy of discussion
um for those exact reasons thank you Mr
chair
representative Edwards uh thank you Mr
chair so so
um the representative just brought up
retentions I'm I'm curious if there was
a discussion in the division on why not
just retain it and work on it and if we
go ahead and and pass it itl I wonder if
on the house floor if a tabling motion
might not be better so that the
representative can work on it and maybe
reintroduce it in January
yes uh well thank you for that
suggestion
um I guess
it just seemed like it needed too much
work for us to retain it and do it in
our committee or in division especially
all the the definitions and the rule
making and that sort of stuff but yes I
would support a tabling motion on the
floor
um
I know that there is a special committee
assigned to this body to discuss this
exact issue that I raised about the
housing affordability and housing crisis
issue and my
instinct is to say um of course that a
retention of the spill to work on some
of the concerns representative McGuire
just raised uh would be an important
tool in their toolbox to address the
issue if we kill it am I correct that
there if we vote to itl today am I
correct that this would be a forbidden
topic for that special committee to even
consider
if if it if Ito prevails they the
subject matter could still be discussed
but not the specifics of the bill if it
was if itl prevailed but if it went to
representative Sweeney uh thank you in
in the division conversation on this
bill
um I did mention I voted for the itl and
I'll vote for itl again today I did
mention my intention to reach out I've
had some initial conversations with some
stakeholders and interest uh interested
parties on this topic
um I I opened myself up volunteered to
to help work on the the bill so I'll
vote itl today I'll talk to the guy that
controls the bandana to Green it on the
table Motion in the chamber because I
further discussion from committee
members seeing none the motion is
inexpeding to legislate on House Bill
534 the clerk will call a roll
thank you Mr chairman representative erf
yes
president McGuire yes Professor Petrie
votes yes representative Emrick yes
representative Griffin yes
representative Mooney yes representative
Edwards yes representative Bean
there's in a hole yes representative
Sweeney yes
represent cameras yes
representative Mueller yes
representative Wallner
Representative norgren no
Representative leishman no
Rosanna Buco uh no
president grassy no
representative Hewitt no
version of Heath no
representative Murray no
representative evil no
Representative no
there's a haken Phillips no
representative Stringham nope
and representative Wilder yes
Mr chairman the vote is 13 to 12.
yes Mr
circus okay Professor hack and Phillips
will write in Minority Report
now
we're moving on to House Bill 576 and
that confusing Amendment you had before
you before with
the front of it was uh
house bill for it 46 Turn the Page and
you are looking at the amendment for the
bill under discussion presently
representative leishman
thank you Mr chairman you're right about
the confusion and I have to thank
representative Sweeney for his efforts
on this and this is again
relative to the admission of commercial
property assessed clean energy sea pace
and like to recognize representative
Sweeney thank you very much
representative Mr chairman so this
amendment seeks to fix the bill
um and to give background on it this
bill passed out of the science
technology and energy committee 15 to 5
with bipartisan support for the C PACE
program it originally had a real fiscal
note but in the amended process in the
first committee policy committee uh the
fiscal impact of the state was severely
limited or wiped out it's enabling
legislation now for municipalities to
adopt a sea pass a commercial uh
Pace Loan program for uh
clean energy projects that they may
pursue it's really built for
municipalities that are populations over
50 000 so it's really two municipalities
in the state of New Hampshire that could
even take advantage of this enabling
legislation the reason for the amendment
that I'll move 692 H
is because when they amended it in the
first committee they essentially made
some issues with the banking system in
which the C Pace loan was going to have
the priority lien on a property above
the mortgage or other any developmental
loans that the the developer the
property owner took out which is not how
we want they didn't look at the banking
elements of it and I spoke with the
chair of Science and Technology when
they had that conversation and they
talked about amending the bill their
internal decision of their committee was
to let Finance deal with that so I met
with the the chairman of Science and
Technology the sponsor of the bill and
and the New Hampshire Bankers
Association to come up with this
amendment to keep the existing policy
and the enabling legislation and the
underlying bill but strengthen it to
protect New Hampshire Banks and and
lenders so that they wouldn't have that
unintended consequence from the original
version that or the original Amendment
as House of the house I think I covered
that it was a confusing issue in the
committee but I think this resolved it
all so I would move adoption of
amendment
2023-0692h to house bill 576.
is there a second for the amendment
representative
is there a need to do a roll call or can
we accept this on a show of hands
all opposed
the amendment carries the motion now is
ought to pass as amended moved by
representative Sweeney representative
clerical call a role on the motion of
ought to pass as amended by Amendment
zero six nine two
thank you
yes
representative
undecided uh
I'm gonna say no
representative McGuire
yes
version of Petrie is undecided
yeah
no
representative uh Griffin yes
Mooney yes I'm sorry wait a minute you
may want to go back because you it looks
it looks like you got some yeses and
no's right let's uh let's do this again
sorry it's a long day uh Earth is no
representative Griffin yes
all right representative Mooney yes
yes representative Edwards no
yeah screw it up all right very good
representative Bean yes
there's a hole no
representative Sweeney yes
there's no cameras no
represent a popovichi Mueller
yes
representative Waller
represent norgren yes there's another
leashman yes original bucco yes
representative grassy yes
yes
representative Heath yes
president Murray yes
representative evil yes representative
yes Reverend haken Phillips
yes
Russia representative Stringham yes
representative Wilder yes representative
Weiler may I uh redo my vote I think I
voted wrong I meant I meant to say yes I
you meant to say yes I meant to say yes
I I got to looking at your page I got
all confused laughs
no it's my fault I meant to say yes and
I said no all right so
you're going to be 21.
to 4.
let me see fine
that's four
all right uh Mr chairman it's 21 to 4.
in favor in favor of the ought to pass
is there a Minority Report on that
parole board one there is you have a
is your minority reported on this one
it does not appear to be a Minority
Report on 576.
division chairs division one you have
anything after this
yeah I'd like to division to head back
to 212 for a few minutes
that's possible
representative emmerich division two yes
division three representative Edwards uh
yes sir division three is in recess
awaiting the completion of this hearing
and we'll stay in this room I think we
probably have a couple hours of work at
least
all right so everyone
division three can stay here division
one and two go to the appropriate rooms
thank you all for your attention and
foreign